mercedes registered dietitian mia sin
shares essentials to make this summer
your healthiest yet
including five-minute field meals
blender free smoothies
and an easy way to upgrade the nutrition
of your backyard barbecue
hey las vegas now summer is here and i
have the healthy essentials you need to
kick off the season
starting with the nutritious breakfast
that will help you stay cool
these eve blender free plant-based
smoothies can be made in three steps
simply run the wheel under water for a
few seconds pop the cubes in a mason jar
cover the cubes with almond milk let it
melt for 20 minutes
and shake each smoothie is made with
organic fruits and vegetables
plant-based protein which adds staying
power in nutrient-dense ingredients like
chia seeds and hemp seeds
plus they have no added sugar you can
order them frozen shipped to your door
with free shipping
at evennutrition.com next i have a five
minute customizable lunch you'll enjoy
all summer long build a satisfying lunch
with protein fiber and good fats with
this five minute wrap hack for my
mediterranean hummus wrap start by
cutting a line from the center of the
tortilla to the bottom
next add hummus to the first quadrant
this fresh cravings hummus comes in
classic and roasted red pepper
is super creamy and made with a short
list of high quality ingredients add
romaine and red onion to the second
quadrant chicken and feta to the third
quadrant
and sun-dried tomatoes and olives to the
fourth fold it up to the side and down
and enjoy chicken adds protein and
veggies add filling fiber while this
hummus offers a balanced mix of good
fats fiber and protein from chilean
extra virgin olive oil
non-gmo chickpeas and savory tahini you
can find it at
smith's in the produce department for
this taco wrap add fresh cravings salsa
which you can find in the produce
section at smithson walmart
spinach ground meat and cheese fold it
up the same way and enjoy
as you grill out this summer try my
veggie bun sliders
veggie buns lower the calories and
carbohydrates and increase the vitamins
minerals and fiber i started with the
primal kitchen condiments including the
unsweetened ketchup
award-winning buffalo sauce and famous
avocado oil mayo besides loading up on
veggies at your grill out
focus on using condiments that are made
with high quality ingredients and free
of added sugar or artificial ingredients
like these by primal kitchen made with
avocado oil and savory spices find them
on amazon and most major grocery stores
my last summer essentials will help you
stay calm and relaxed
all season long keep zao ashwagandha on
hand which is an ancient indian herb
that may help the body manage stress or
make your own calming spa wellness water
with
cherry-flavored zao kom now formulated
with ashwagandha and other herbs with
potential calming effects like lemon
balm and hawthorne berry find both at
walmart
and soundnutrition.com research also
suggests that certain foods may help
promote feelings of calm like nuts seeds
and whole grains rich in magnesium and
mackerel and pasture-raised eggs sources
of omega-3 fats
i hope you enjoyed these recipes and
tips you can find them at my website
nutritionbymia.com
and nutritionbymia on instagram where i
also share meal ideas
and nutrition tips daily